optimal subgaussian mean estimation in
very high dimensions i'm paul valiant
and this is joint work with jasper lee
today i'm going to tell you about two
problems which at first glance don't
seem particularly related
the first problem which gives us talk
its name is mean estimation this is the
classical challenge from statistics that
given samples from today a high
dimensional distribution we want to
estimate
the distribution's mean as accurately as
possible given our data
more on this in a moment
the second challenge which has a rather
different flavor is that of coming up
with good tail bounds and high
dimensions the setting is we have a sum
of independent bounded random vectors of
some total covariance and we want to
come up with a high probability bound on
the distance from their mean
the guiding idea today
is that a high dimensional gaussian
distribution
looks like a spherical shell
to illustrate this consider the
distribution of the length of standard
gas and distributed random variable in
in d dimensions normalized by one over
root d
in one dimension this doesn't look very
much like a spherical gel but as you
increase the dimension
you can see that the radius starts
adhering more and more tightly to one
the issue is that previous tail bounds
don't seem to reflect this behavior
one way of saying this is that previous
tail bounds seem to have
an essentially uniform shape for all
dimensions d and fail to reflect the
ground truth behavior that these
distributions are
converging in increasing dimension to a
spherical shell
so these are the two challenges that
i'll tell you about today
let me more fully introduce the mean
estimation problem now
the challenge is given some data how do
we best estimate the mean of the
underlying distribution
mean estimation shows up as a subroutine
in a variety of computational settings
but it's also one of the most important
statistical primitives for dealing with
real world data
to use this as an example supposing
you're running a big experiment and
you're collecting data from the real
world
how can you best estimate the mean
i'm illustrating this in one dimension
to emphasize that this problem remains
hard even in one dimension so given this
data how do you estimate the mean
well one good thing place to start is
the sample mean
the sample mean works great for
gaussians and many other nice
distributions
however suppose we keep collecting data
and we get a sample that's really really
far to the right
is this an outlier should we take it
seriously did we get unlucky
if there's only one of them maybe you
throw it out what if you get two of them
so
okay
we saw two outliers out of the 10 data
points we collected what does this mean
well this data that we collected is
consistent with a world where the
expected number of outliers we see is
say as low as one tenth maybe as high as
four tenths
and i'll use this to introduce the
viewpoint that you should have about
this problem so in some sense given the
data we're trying to figure out what are
the most extreme distributions that
could have plausibly led to the data we
observed
and then given these plausible
distributions
find an estimate that is accurate enough
with respect to all such distributions
so meanwhile there's some distributions
that could less plausibly have led to
our data so if this um
event far to the right actually has a
true probability of one out of ten
thousand
then it's pretty unlikely for us to see
it twice in 10 data points
but i mean pretty unlikely well only
about one in a million unlikely
and
how you should deal with this data
crucially needs to depend on the
confidence with which you want to return
your answer
in some areas like physics the standards
for publication that demand that you
need to be more than one and one in a
million confident
in order to publish a paper so if we
were publishing a physics paper we would
need to account for
the case that our data is generated from
a distribution
like
like this one
so the simple point here is that the
optimal algorithm must depend on our
desired confidence so our goal is given
n samples from an unknown distribution p
we want to estimate the mean of p to
within l2 distance epsilon except with
probability of failure delta
in other words we want to understand the
optimal trade-off between the number of
samples n the accuracy epsilon and the
desired confidence level delta
we're focusing today on the high
dimensional case where we define
dimensionality in terms of what's called
the effective dimension if you haven't
seen this before this is the ratio of
the trace of the covariance
divided by the maximal variance in any
direction this is a very natural notion
and behaves as you would expect for
example for a sphere the effective
dimension just equals the ambient
dimension
for sphere the variance is the same in
every direction
and the trace just adds up one copy of
this per dimension
thus this ratio just equals the
dimension
some distributions
may have covariance matrix that looks
more like a pancake where there's
several directions of big variants and
several directions of small variants
here too the effective dimension does
just what you would like it essentially
counts the number of dimensions with big
variants and ignores the the dimension
to the small variance
so i'm armed with this notion of
effective dimension i can now tell you
what we mean by the high dimensional
regime
today we're going to look at the case
where the effective dimension is
essentially bigger than the square of
the logarithm of the desired confidence
so one way to get started here is by
asking
how well can we do on a gaussian
distribution and this can serve as a
benchmark in general
so for gaussian distribution the best
thing to do is just return the sample
mean and it's worthwhile figuring out
exactly how well this performs
so given n samples from a gaussian of
covariance sigma
what's the sample mean do
well as we saw earlier
samples from a gaussian in high enough
dimension
adhere to a spherical shell
so except with tiny probability the
answer will be
extremely close to
the square root of the trace over n
provided the dimension is high enough
so this is the case for gaussian and the
algorithmic question is
to what degree can we get an algorithm
that not just on a gaussian but on any
unknown distribution of unknown
covariance
we want to approach
this performance of a gaussian
so
what can we actually accomplish
algorithmically
the punch line is that we can actually
attain this even down to the one plus
level of one factor
provided the dimension the effective
dimension is high enough
and for large enough n
there's been a lot of prior work in this
area including a lot of recent work in
this area even in one dimension
this area was in some sense kicked off
by the classic median of means algorithm
more recently a line of work culminating
in our upcoming fox publication has
essentially resolved this question in 1d
the high dimensional case though looks
much more complicated
it was only
remarkably recently that the first
algorithms with even constant factor
sample optimality showed up
and
at the cost of a
huge
computation time which has been improved
since then with
after a lot of work
this problem has also been approached
from a rather different robust
statistics perspective
where instead of a medium of mean style
algorithm it uses an iterative filtering
approach
so in some sense this slide should
convince you that this problem is hard
from two perspectives um
from a computational complexity
perspective
the amount of work it's taken to improve
the computation time shows that there's
a lot going on here
and from a statistics perspective the
fact that it took so long to get even
any algorithm
um
is kind of scary and also even though
these are constant factor optimal the
constants embedded in these are often
huge
so one paper i looked at recently has a
constant of 480 000 squared
by contrast today
the story is remarkably clean i'm going
to tell you a linear time algorithm
that is sample optimal to within one
plus level of one factor
and
i think you'll believe me when i show it
to you the algorithm is extremely simple
but at the cost of that the algorithm
only works in very high dimensions
so our motivation for this work
is that we want to do mean estimation
gaussians are a natural first case to
look at and in some sense the most
interesting thing about high dimensional
gaussians is that they behave like
spherical shells
so to take a closer look at this
the distribution of the error of a
gaussian distribution except with
probability delta
is described by the following expression
where the first term is exactly the
square root trace thing describing the
radius of the spherical shell and the
second term
um
goes to zero with increasing dimensions
so this becomes more clear if we
rearrange slightly and you can check my
arithmetic with this with the definition
of effective dimension
so the error becomes the square root of
trace times one plus the second term
where
if
the effective dimension is a lot bigger
than
log of our confidence
namely this assumption
then the second term vanishes
and the
tail of the gaussian converges to
essentially just the spherical shell of
radius square trace
so given this guessing behavior
we're motivated to ask can we extend
these tail bounds beyond gaussians
a good place to start here is to
understand the one-dimensional bernstein
bound describing how tail bounds
on sums of independent random variables
in one dimension that are each bounded
by some radius r
intuitively the bernstein bound combines
two types of information
it combines information about the
variance of each variable
but also a global bound r
on the support of each random variable
as you can see the denominator here
blends these two types of information
together
the first term that we call the gaussian
term
is in terms of just the variance and if
the first term dominates the denominator
then you can see this ratio is just the
standard tail for a gaussian
however as the radius bound gets bigger
these two terms start interaction
interacting and the interaction shows
how the gaussian bounds gracefully
degrade in the presence of outliers that
radius up to r
so this is a one-dimensional bernstein
bound
and in this paper we generalize this to
high dimensions
the generalization
is fairly natural
so given independent random vectors now
in high dimensions each bounded by some
radius r
we aim to describe
how closely the tail will adhere to the
spherical shell of radius square root of
trace
so for any gap t
that's not too much bigger than this
radius
we'll come up with a bound on the
probability that the radius is t more
than the spherical shell
and indeed this expression is very
similar to the one-dimensional
expression where there's a gaussian term
coming from the maximum directional
variance and the second term coming from
the radius
it'll be a little bit easier to
re-express this theorem um using a
different parameter gamma instead of t
um which is which will make it look a
bit less like the bernstein band but
will be easier for us to use
so
under this reprimandisation we're now
asking what's the probability that the
radius is one plus gamma times the
radius of the spherical shell
so here the denominator has two terms
and if the first term dominates then
this expression essentially reduces to
the exponential of
half gamma squared times the effective
dimension
namely
um the probability of being
gamma close to the spherical shell
decays exponentially with the dimension
thus showing that for any bounded
distribution
the tails will adhere
extremely close to the spherical shell
and closer with increasing dimensions
so given this new tool this high
dimensional tail bound how can we use it
to do effective mean estimation in high
dimensions
well one of the issues immediately is
that the bernstein bound applies to
bounded distributions but we want to do
mean estimation in general
so how do we
make our distribution bounded so that we
can apply
the bernstein bound well one simple idea
is just to
collect some data throw out all samples
that are outside of some ball of radius
r
and then
the samples conditioned on being inside
the ball of radius r will come from a
conditional distribution that's bounded
and we can apply the theorem
and thus um
inside the ball we we get the desired
spherical shell behavior
so
the first step of throwing out all
samples outside some ball
this gets better as the radius of the
ball gets bigger we're doing less damage
to the distribution if we throw things
outside if we throw things that are
outside of a big ball
the second step though
um
performs better if the radius is smaller
this theorem has better performance for
smaller r
so it takes some analysis to to make
sure that there's actually an r that's
satisfies both regimes
but still algorithmically given some
data
how do we start
um how do we pick up ball of radius r
well here's our algorithm i think you'll
agree it's
really simple
um so step one is that we
find the center of the ball by roughly
estimating the mean with just classic
median of means algorithm on each
coordinate
step two
we pick some number s and throw out the
s farther samples from our center
returning the mean of what remains and
this is the algorithm
so i just want to say a few high-level
things about the algorithms first of all
it's linear time essentially the most
complicated thing we need to do here is
just compute medians
second thing it turns out that the
number of samples we throw at s can be
almost any upper bound on
the square of the log of our confidence
so
this has a sort of remarkable
implication that we can get an algorithm
that simultaneously works for many
different confidence levels delta this
is called in the literature a multiple
delta estimator
and it's impossible in one dimension
finally just as a high-level comment
um this algorithm throws out log squared
or confidence number of samples which
contrasts with the optimal
one-dimensional algorithm from our fox
paper
in one dimension you have to throw out
log number of samples whereas here we're
throwing at log squared number of
samples and this gives some high level
sense of perhaps why our approach here
can't extend transparently to the low
dimensional case
our algorithm's error is one plus one
factor optimal it's intriguing that we
get such a tight algorithm algorithm
from a perhaps not so tight tail bound
i'll illustrate this with a diagram
so consider the probability distribution
of mean estimation error
so as we've discussed the ground truth
will adhere extremely tightly
to a spherical shell
what if
however we have a tail bound that
adheres to the spherical shell but maybe
not so tightly are we okay
well even though the red and the blue
curves differ a lot
in the y direction
what we care about is the delta
probability tails
and
the delta probability tail of the error
even though these two curves differ a
lot in the y direction is very similar
in the radial direction
in fact the ratio because both of these
are so close to the spherical shell is
going to be one plus one
this is why at a high level getting this
spherical shell tail bound is a big win
given this tail bound our algorithm is
really simple and it works for simple
robust reasons
the fact that this tailbone
has such a
simple and robust application here gives
us hope that perhaps its tailbone will
be useful in general
so
because this bound is the main tool of
the paper it's worth saying a few words
about its proof
the issue is that we're trying to
understand a tailbone on the radius of a
random vector in high dimensional space
well one very simple way to get started
is by taking one-dimensional turn-off
bounds in every direction x
so to draw a picture we're trying to
prove some bound on the probability of a
vector being outside of a sphere
and for any direction x we can just draw
a yellow line perpendicular to x and
compute
bound
the probability of um
being on on the far side of this yellow
line
we can do this for every x
it's not hard to check that if every
point outside the sphere is hit by a at
least a c fraction of these turn off
bounds then this
yields a bound of the probability of
being outside the sphere of
one over c times the average turnoff
bound
because c appears in the denominator
here this suggests that in fact it might
be to our advantage
to move this yellow line towards the
origin
so that each of these turn off regions
covers a bigger fraction of the sphere
we'll parameterize this by a distance
beta which we'll choose later
a second issue
is that
probability distributions in high
dimensions can be very spiky in the
sense that maybe they're supported only
on the axes
and if the turn off direction x is
aligned with the spike
then the bands that we get might blow up
badly
so one very simple way of
trying to address this is that
any support point y whose projection to
the direction x exceeds some threshold p
we just set aside and deal with
differently
so given beta and p these parameterize
our analysis
and simply optimize over beta and p to
get the best bound
so
while this may seem a bit unprincipled
um
and uh
it uses simple techniques
the reason why we get such a tight bound
is essentially the same reason that
turn-off bands are so tight the
exponential in the moment generating
function means typically very narrow
regions contribute most of the bound and
therefore it's enough to find a beta and
p that perform well on a narrow region
so
even though these techniques are fairly
direct and look fairly ad hoc
their good performance is essentially
the same reason that turn-off bands get
good performance and this optimization
technique is a
simple and natural approach that
yields the surprisingly tight and new
bounds that that drive our paper
so i'll end by briefly asking how tight
is our new vector tail bound
this bound is parameterized by
at least the three parameters
gamma the effective dimension and this
ratio between our radius bound and the
radius of the spherical shell
so
these three different parameters
convey that there's potentially a lot of
structure here
so to simplify this expression a little
bit
this
ratio
essentially falls into two regimes
depending upon which term in the
denominator is bigger so up to constant
factors in the exponent we can simplify
this as just gamma squared times the min
of these two things
so this is an upper bound to understand
how tight it is we need to understand
lower bounds this upper bound applies
for all distributions
the lower bound is going to come from a
single distribution
each lower band is going to come from a
single distribution whose tail we can
analyze
one distribution worth looking at is the
gaussian
and
as we pointed out the
gamma squared times the effective
dimension
portion of this upper bound essentially
represents the spherical shell behavior
of the gaussian so for this one regime
where where the effective dimension term
dominates here the performance of our
upper bound in fact matches that of the
gaussian
a different lower bound regime worth
considering
is a much spikier
less uniform distribution where the
distribution is supported only on the
axes and is far out
on the axes as our radius r bound will
allow
there's in fact
two sub-regimes of this that have rather
different behavior one is when the tail
is likely to be along a single axis
the other is when
the most extreme tail events are likely
to come in intermediate directions with
contributions from supports at many
support points at many different axes
so
our upper bound has these two different
regimes depending on which term
dominates and we have three different
regimes for lower bound
i'm going to draw a picture a diagram
that tries to convey what's going on
here
so
i'll depict the three-dimensional
parameter space
by projecting to a triangle where um
points near one vertex of the triangle
correspond to one of these three
different parameters being higher than
the other two
so
the two different parameter regimes of
the upper bound
are when the effective dimension is
bigger or smaller than the root trace
term which corresponds to being in the
left or the right side of the triangle
represented by this cross-hashed black
pattern here
meanwhile the three different lower
bounds
the regions in which each of them
dominate the other lower bounds are
depicted by these three colored regions
that match the three lower bounds
and
okay so
um
conveniently
the
crosshatch region
and the black region have the same bound
here
indicating that for the entire right
half of the triangle
our upper bound is in fact tight
on the left half though the situation is
much more complicated we have three
different lower bounds that each
dominate in different regions of the
triangle and none of these three
expressions match the corresponding
upper bound here gamma squared times
this root trace thing
so
our upper bound is tight for half the
parameter space and for half the
parameter space things seem rather
complicated
so i think it's worth looking at this
structure and
because it's
such a high dimensional parameter space
um this diagram hints that there's
actually a lot of struct a lot of
further structure worth understanding
with these new vector tail bands
contributions our main result today is a
simple linear time one plus little low
of one factor optimal mean estimation
algorithm that works in very high
dimensions
the tool we use to get this is a new
vector bernstein inequality capturing
the intuition that high dimensional
gaussians behave essentially like
spherical shells and extending this
intuition to the tails of arbitrary
bounded distributions
two new contributions which i haven't
mentioned
um one is
a new uh
tight one plus level of one factor lower
bound for mean estimation from an
algorithmic perspective
so
in the high dimensional regime this one
plus little of one
accurate analysis
hasn't really been discussed before
and
these lower bounds
in principle would be useful for future
work along this line
finally
the coordinate wise median of means
algorithm we use as a subroutine and we
have a new type analysis of this which
removes a spurious dependence on the
ambient dimension d
okay thanks